and I thought it'd be dead or in jail
and I'm here okay well you didn't live a
crazy life so don't say no but you live
any crimes have you ever done any crime
uh-huh one what oh I did one crime well
why was that because I did Walgreens or
savon or one of those [ __ ] stores and
I saw the worst hat in the world yeah it
was a baseball hat that was white with
green Tiger neon green tiger stripes
zebra stripes all over it yeah and I
thought wow that's the worst hat I've
seen in my life now at the time it was
I've seen way worse hat sense yeah but
at the time I was 20-something I saw
this hat is worse not ever saw said dad
hat is awful it shouldn't be for sale so
I thought you know what I'm going to
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take
the hat I'm gonna put it on my head and
I'm gonna pay for whatever it is I have
and if the guy doesn't say anything to
me while I'm wearing the hat buying
whatever I needed that wall gonna walk
out I'm gonna walk out and that's my hat
and then I'm gonna throw it away
yep and that's what happened and he
didn't say [ __ ] well you have you done
and I did that and I did that and I
don't even think that was a crime
because he just watched me do it I was
like eating give a [ __ ] I don't know bye
guys
sometimes the only time I did a crime
was was because my friend was a bit of a
criminal kind of a bad guy and we were
in a pet store and I was 25 2002 budget
Perry I know we're in a pet store and my
friend lawyer friend goes my friend
picks up a snake and he goes I want a
snake it was a boa constrictor a
beautiful one and he goes put this in
your shirt now and I go what and he puts
it in my shirt and I go oh and I hold
and they go let's get out of here and I
stole a monkey a boa constrictor he
wanted me to do it he does it he would
do all kinds he did crazy [ __ ] he stole
it but I remember he can't hold on yeah
we're a trees path yeah so you put the
bow constrict in your shirt and then
just straw walk out I was like I guess I
was like a constrictor doing and it was
in like Virginia and I didn't want to
steal it and I go and my friend goes you
just committed a felony bro and I went
that's not true I was like I was like 25
way too old to do something like that
and I Ellen no but I was lying falls
victim to peer pressure at 25 I don't
know why you
Virginia did it so why were you in
Petsmart at them yes no we were in a you
guys molest kids that are in it in fact
we were in West Virginia and I believe
the town called Morgantown hey oh if
you're a town don't have the last part
of your town be town I mean Morgan I
call it Morgan yes so get this so I I go
I can't steal something I can't do that
is ridiculous right so I take it I go
and I went back and the girl who was on
you know working their time a young girl
like a college girl I went back and I
gave I said how much was that boa
constrictor and she goes what Poconos
how much are the ball constrictors
she goes what I was and I gave her money
and I [ __ ] walked
yeah so at the end of the day I didn't
he kept it he gave it to a kid that
killed the kid I'm not really stolen
anything like that and I was like commit
a crime my shirt I go I guess I gotta
walk out now right 25:12 that IIM sorry
I stole a hat and you stole a life she
does told a life okay man that's
horrible
no don't you're going to help - eew if
you die yeah that's the thing that's
gonna mess it up and I'm gonna be right
there and I'll be like oh you only stole
the hat get up into heaven
I beg you stole of what a snake a real
snake a life you go down paid for it
does it matter you don't put a price on
my intention yeah it was it was the
intention I committed that so that's a
that's a misdemeanor yeah it's tough
enough felony felony has to be over I
think some [ __ ] there's a it was a rare
snake it was 15 grand yeah but I did it
like then we killed everybody in the
store oh Jesus did that know that heart
is the beating average and they caught
me and I I had that we had too often I'm
not going to jail I had to off everybody
cuz I couldn't well yeah mafia stuff you
know what when I was like six or seven
you know when those candy machines were
you want 25 no definitely not I can't be
story yes last 37 I don't know but I
took this guy he was making copies you
know I was a key
kid I was with my brother who wanted
money for candy put the five cents in
you know a little and then take the
candy so I went up there I was talking
to him and then put my pinkie on a dime
and then just scrolled it over oh did
that's and and then I put it in the the
candy machine my brother getting candy
well homeboys making copies and he must
have knew exactly what he so I'm talking
my brother you know [ __ ] I'm like
seven my brother's eight or nine yeah
and he great he knew exactly what
happened he grabbed me by the hand
lift me up whoa the [ __ ] out of whoa
nice you deserve it have you ever had
you deserve it and I think you actually
probably still deserve more
it's great I scraped a car and like bad
hold it and I know this way and I put a
note on the you know I said I said you
know I I scraped your car I never heard
back from the person I put it right I
said scraped your car I'll pay for it
and never heard back and somebody said
that's really honest of you the guy was
walking and I go I go it's not honest
it's called common decency yeah but as a
kid my father broke a taillight and he
said let me get a piece of paper and I
said I said I was young and I said let's
just get home yeah I said my father gave
me my father sat me down because let me
explain something to you I'll explain
what a man does when you do when you do
damage you [ __ ] pay for that damn
yeah we forgot it but but but you never
forget yeah but you know what your dad
is wrong though you know I mean the
other person was wrong place wrong time
and you kind of just can only get you
get to leave oh man no dude no you got
to do the right thing Chris I feel like
you would I feel like you would write a
note you draw a picture of your hand
giving the finger I would just draw a
[ __ ] beautiful drawing of a panda and
just put it there and put my bad and
then a sad face and be like call me and
then a bunch of numbers but with most of
the numbers just question mark super
[ __ ] up yeah did a Batman villain
[ __ ] hit in a car I was I was a girl
in New York City and you were a girl in
New York little girl person I was with a
girl and she bashed me a car full of
rough-looking Italian dudes and they
can't wait to buy and she
I get out and he goes like this he goes
I got to see some money for this I got
some money for this yeah I got it and
she goes excuse me but you backed in me
I backed into you she goes and she
starts mouthing off to these guys for
[ __ ] rough dudes in it's it's you
know car boy get her and she you know
how girls can get you in a fight yeah
they they could have turned around and
just beaten the living [ __ ] out of me
and I'm trying to play like you know and
she's like don't talk to them difficult
losers
you're an [ __ ] I'm a loser honey I'm
a loser she goes yeah you're a [ __ ]
loser
it was so bad and I finally figured out
a way and you murdered those guys didn't
you and I and I had to off cable on your
wall or time you had to off all of them
you know what I you know what I [ __ ]
did well because I didn't know her and
she was such an [ __ ]
I got a cabin left yeah really yeah I
don't know her know her yeah all right
she was long she was I was like oh
you're a bad person you're affecting you
you're trying to make this on them and
these are really and they both came from
the same world so they know how to speak
to each other I was like gab please see
ya see ya I go I'm gonna go go to the
ATM I'm like with the ATM that's like
the woman I was on a date when the woman
was being so rude to the waiter I was on
a first date she was being such a deal
breaker dude
I mean she was so rude and I went and
I've never done this I looked at her I
go you're bad person and my life is too
short and you're treating the waiter
like [ __ ] I got up to go to the bathroom
and I never done stuff like that yeah I
have I talked about I talked about a
girl when we first started doing the
podcast how shoes mean to wait at this
type place she like made fun of the lady
because she didn't speak very good
English and saw Zika this is [ __ ] came
over look if you're mean to them she
called me like two or three two or three
years later cuz she was on she was at
her job and someone's like oh I heard of
the fighting the kid Baba and they
started talking she said gosh he broke
up with a girl cuz this and it was her
really oh my god no it was I was going
through a rough time I want to apologize
oh I don't even remember that's wild
weird right yeah yeah how much you would
know this person ie I would I don't help
me what we are left have you ever left
any shitty dates although you're tied
down now
although you're sucking on the teat now
yeah I have I know one time I was out
with a girl that I mean god this was
years ago and she was telling me she has
a key she had a kid and she was telling
me that she she like had a baby the one
she had the baby she wanted to kill it
for it yeah okay okay he open I was like
what man and she was like yeah I had
this really bad I wanted to kill the
baby and it was really rough Jesus
crying now it's okay I'm went out with
her again Chris Chris by the way if
she's superhot you're still gonna have
sex with it you should be like damn
that's crazy and then you don't gonna
bang the baby killer he's there anytime
you it maybe you would know Brian
wouldn't know I'm sure there is I had
someone reach out to me like hey I can't
believe you're on tinder Bo I'm like I'm
not on tinder
you know you get dams and this girl goes
hey just want you know there's some guy
pretending to be you he's lying updates
on Tim oh no and I was like I don't want
to tell you I'm not on tinder oh
definitely not an agenda that's fishing
you I guarantee there's a fake town and
daliyah counter I get my I don't know if
yeah yeah I know they're hydeia people
people ruin me about it when you see my
back ripple and I pull myself up like a
champ like a champ thirty times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift